yo what's up guys we are csio and today
we're with buzzfeed and we're going to
be playing a game of who's who
so check it out
who is most likely to start singing out
of nowhere
i'm pointing to everyone so everybody
honestly yeah like now i feel like we're
singing a lot of what we're going to be
coming out with which is our new
album deja vu and our new single that's
coming out tonight
i think i've heard all of us sing a
little piece of it today at least who is
the most likely
to forget choreography routine
i feel like i struggle a lot with choreo
maybe i just go
and get lost in the moment of just
looking at the band of the crowd
and i don't remember where to be honest
but i was connecting with a fan that she
was
uh doing a video or something i remember
singing to that camera like singing
right away straight up
boom to her and kind of kind of go like
this
and i forgot everything like to
everything i just stay there like
we're in the middle of choreography and
just like i was like
just like one spot empty you know and
that's chris doing his thing it's not
even his part who is most likely
to get the choreography on the first try
what i'm gonna defend myself i always
get the quarter right away
yo we have uh honestly gotten better at
remembering it um for one of our music
videos i recorded about two weeks ago
we uh did a zoom call to uh like to
practice a new choreography we had like
two days to remember it and it's pretty
good like the korea is not
that easy who has the best style
hold up you guys know not disgusting
let me show i don't my shoes think
everyone has found their style over the
years
who is most likely to create the next
viral dance challenge
[Music]
i directed uh uh saddam's dick talk as
well as eric's
hey
our number of photos we have in our in
our gallery
we're always recording so much moments
in eric's phone especially
he's always recording everything if
anyone would ever find that jeez
don't say it i don't know what we do i
don't know what we do who's most likely
to make
all the other members
i think between uh chris eric and zab
let me be crazy with it
mostly yeah mostly harry oh he's not me
[Laughter]
who is most likely to send memes in the
good text
[Laughter]
i think chris enjoyed who's the best at
doing impressions of other members
yeah i think it's richard richard is
really good yeah yeah i don't know bro
i don't even think we've we've seen each
other do our own impressions
i can do some spongebob if you want to
boys
i'm ready
[Applause]
ready
[Applause]
who can sing the highest notes job
you guys will actually hear in the album
like we actually kind of go off you will
hear it who is most likely to write the
next scene show it
hey we all we all right everybody
yo what's up we are cnc oh thank you so
much for everyone watching buzzfeed we
want to remind you guys that hero
our new single is out with the video you
can also pre-order our album deja vu
coming out very soon we love you see you
soon peace
you